we begin in texas in the united states
where authorities have discovered the
bodies of at least 46 people in an
abandoned truck first responders were
called to the truck on the outskirts of
san antonio after a cry for help was
heard
officials say a further 16 people
including four children were taken to
hospital the location is 250 kilometers
from the u.s mexican border and is a
major transit route for people smugglers
a spokesman for the san antonio fire
department described the condition of
the survivors and the shock of first
responders when they arrived at the
scene
the patients that we saw were hot to the
touch
they were suffering
from heat stroke heat exhaustion
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer
but there was no
visible working ac unit on that rig
we are currently putting those 60
members through critical incident stress
debriefing
again uh we're not supposed to open up a
truck and see
stacks of bodies in there
let's cross over now to mike dewald in
san francisco mike what more can you
tell us
well we're starting to learn more about
just who was on this truck as
investigators tried to pick up the
pieces we've heard from officials in
honduras and guatemala
that they believe that that migrants may
have been on but really the
investigation continues as to just
where this truck came from where it was
going
it's really a reflection of the
challenges that are being faced along
the border
it's common for it's a very dangerous
route it's common for
deaths to occur uh but the scale that
this this happened is like nothing
that's happened in in this country in
quite a while so uh investigators really
looking for answers here as to uh you
know
what happened and what went wrong
i understand there was an arrest made
that's right there have been a couple
arrests made and
investigators again looking for answers
there
no word uh as to what's been gleaned
from that uh but certainly uh
investigators will have many questions
uh for for those uh involved in this
incident
uh you you've mentioned there are uh is
some uh it's not the first time that
something like this has happened the
biden administration has been under
criticism uh in regards to border
controls uh what if at all has changed
since trump and his building of a wall
along parts of the border of mexico
immigration has really been a challenge
going back administrations if you're the
biden administration you're looking for
a bipartisan solution you're looking for
a path to citizenship so those migrants
don't have to make this dangerous
journey that there's there's a chance
for for them to go through you know a
route where this is possible uh with the
trump administration you had a more
hard-line stance where it's you know
close off the border that met much
stronger stance which brought
controversies of its own and really
there hasn't been a bipartisan solution
yet to find the answer to this
journalist mike dewalt thank you very
much